so
okay so yeah nicole said i'm ryan seddon
um you can find me on twitter i have a
blog called the cssninja.com
i also work on modernizer um
and i work for a company in australia uh
called seek which is like a job search
website so
monster.com i think you guys have here
uh yeah so i hail all the way from
melbourne australia it was a long flight
here 25 hours all up
um if there's uh one cool thing you need
to know about melbourne is
uh it was founded by batman
that's a fact whether or not it's the
actual batman is beyond the point
so uh you're probably thinking
checkboxes are pretty boring you know
usually you just agree to the terms and
conditions
they just go away
that's because maybe you are incorrect
because
because when we use uh the czech studio
class we can get some awesome stuff
happening
and that's a custom checkbook using
check and it's just putting up an
animated gif from the background so it's
all powered by
css only uh
so it essentially allows you to create
uh interaction with our javascript so it
gives you
um state css so it gives you an on state
it gives you an off state and allows you
to
react to a user's click without having
do event listeners with javascript
so the first thing you might think of is
you can do custom
checkboxes and radios
this is a cool example that i took from
a developer that leah talked about who
did those uh bon bon buttons
he did a really cool example of doing
radio buttons whereas a shiny dot looks
like it travels
through and then the further away you
click the faster it looks like it moves
and that's incredibly simple so all it
is is just in the markup this is an
input and a label
and what we do is we kind of throw away
the input and we just use that for the
it's checked ability so whether it's
checked or unchecked and what we do is
we style
the actual label and we do that by using
the direct sibling combinator selector
which is the plus
so that allows me to say i want to
target a label that's directly followed
by an input
so all those styles pick up and then
we've got the checked class on the input
so i can say well when the input's
checked i want to target the label
change the cells on that and then the
little neat trick here to
get all the other labels and inputs to
react to make it look like that dot's
flowing through the whole the whole list
of radio buttons
you can use the general signaling
combinator which is will target any
any sibling not the direct not just the
direct one
and then that shiny dot is just um just
a background image using radial
gradients
i've uh haven't included all the
prefixes because otherwise that'll be
huge
use border radius which we all learn
about and then the trick down here is
just transitioning the background
position
and then using a cubic bezier curve to
give it the illusion that it's speeding
up the longer way it is
um liver has got a really cool website
called cubicbezio.com
which allows you to visualize all those
um all those animations it's really
handy
so i wrote an article about this
technique of doing custom
radios and check boxes a couple years
ago now
so you can check out my blog these
slides will be up
after the talk so you can check it out
another example
is the tree menu so have you ever used a
file system in a
any computer you can expand folders
i'm sure you've all used that before
and that's so that's using checkboxes
believe it or not
so it's just an ordered list and then so
that can go infinitely deep and you can
have infinite amount of
checkboxes and the css is relatively
simple to accomplish that so
you once again have an input in the
label and you
style the label to have the plus or
minus and it's got like the folder name
and then below that you've got like a
children ordered list
to denote that it's like a subtree of
that uh
folded list so i've simplified the css
so i just fit in here so just picked out
the important bits um so we use
the uh general sibling combinator again
to target all ordered lists that are
inside a checked input
and we can set uh the height to auto so
it'll just expand to show all the
all its children we push it in to give
the illusion like it's
you know below that folder
and we use a few after and before
generated content to add the icon so the
plus and minus depending if it's checked
or unchecked
and just using a sprite and then all we
do here is that initially all list items
are display none and then when the
input's checked they're all blocked so
it's just like expanding the folder
really simple stuff i wrote an article
about that too
so if you want to check that out so
it's a bit you know that's okay to be
boring
so i uh i wrote a um
thing called bootleg.css uh
affectionately called the dodgy version
of bootstrap
because i took a whole bunch of
bootstrap plugins and made them css only
using checkboxes
uh so the first one is the drop down so
this is all
i've just removed all the javascript and
just kept a bootstrap css file
so you can see now uh i've made this red
just so for visually you can see what's
going on
but essentially these drop downs here if
you can see them they're just labels
and when i click that that checks the
the checkbox that then
shows the menu below it
and this red background is actually
another label
that expands to the full width of the
window this is an iframe so that's why
it's not expanding the full width
so then i can click anywhere and dismiss
it so you're used to clicking somewhere
and i just click over here i don't want
that menu up anymore
just to give that interactivity and
basically this label targets another
input that
just makes sure everything's closed and
that's a common sort of technique i use
throughout some of these other plugins
so the markup is exactly the same as the
um
the bootstrap example uh this is
bootstrap 2. i'm not sure if preset 3's
changed
uh yeah so you can see here i've the
label is
that drop down button and then it's just
got the unordered list which shows the
menu items
and then i've got that label down here
which when this one's checked it expands
to the full
width of the window so you can click
anywhere to dismiss it quite easily
and then just down the bottom this is
the input that it targets to make sure
everything's hidden
saying any false negatives
and then the css is really easy so
initially for the dismiss
i have a display none but i have a whole
bunch of styles set up to say it's
position fixed and it expands to the
full
container of the window and then all i
have down here is on the input i say
when that input's checked or sorry the
radio is checked
i display the drop down menu and dismiss
and set the display block and then all
the bootstrap styles take care of how
everything else looks
there's a collapse or accordion
once again i've got the the red showing
there so you can see when i when i
activate one of them it actually
displays a label at the top so i can
then just dismiss it
keep showing it
and this uh also has um
a so it has like a top level collapsible
radio button that gets targeted to make
sure if i
have none of them checked and they're
all collapsed and you don't get any odd
styling
uh i've got the input up here for each
specific item that needs to be opened
and closed and then i've got the label
here and i just use the four attribute
to make sure i can target it
the reason the input is not inside this
accordion header is because of the
limitations of using css i can't work my
way out
of a container i have to work my way
down using uh the general sibling
combinator or the direct signaling
combinator the plus or the tilde
and then so the case is here so i use a
trick so you may have noticed that um
like this one's a different height to
the other ones but it still expands to
just be the height of the content
so you can use a trick of using max
height rather than height
so originally i think now safari 6 and
the latest chrome
can transition from height 0 to height
auto
but before you can do that and other
browsers can't so you can use a trick
max height so initially when it's not
checked it's got max height zero the
height is set to auto
we set up the transition uh when it's
checked uh
we set the height to 500 so it may not
be 500 it might be like 100 pixels
and it will just expand to its container
but then you get some weird timing
issues um because it's doing max heights
trying to calculate it so
uh when it's when it's collapsing it
will collapse over 200 milliseconds
and then i adjust the duration here to
say it's over 700 milliseconds so they
sort of look like they're happening at
the same time
but you still get some odd behavior
we've got some tabs um this is where you
start to get to the ugly side of this
this hack
and you have to have specific markup
placement and the css selectors get
really nasty
so the markup here we have to have each
top level tab item has to be input label
it can't be inside any sort of ordered
list
or unordered list because of the
selector restriction
and then each container is shown and so
then we get
huge selectors like this because of the
constraints
so i need to target the first input and
they do
n of type and not in child because we've
got input label input label if i did
nth child then it would get the wrong
item so we
make sure that it's an input and it's
the first one and if it's checked
then we find the tab content sibling and
then we look inside that
and we find the first uh div so we want
to when the first one's checked we want
to show you the first content
and vice versa when it's unchecked it's
displaying on
modals that's cool so you get the the
same
same transition you got it fades in the
background it pops down
i've made the background red so you can
see see it fading a bit better
um i can click there dismiss it i can
click the cross so like the normal
behavior that you're used to with the
bootstrap model
uh so yeah the that label is
styled to look like a button but really
it's a label
we've got the input and then you've got
the modal container
so these need to be at sibling level so
in order for me to go when inputs check
target that modal and show it
and do the animations and then we use uh
the closed modal input to do the overlay
so when the when you've launched a modal
uh we use
the that red background you saw was a
just a label that's expanded to the
the full width of the window um and so
that's used to close it and
and as the transparent background that
you get that you used to seeing with
modals
and the css is um is really easy
so you've got the using the general
simulink combinator the target the model
in case there's any elements in between
the input and actual modal container
this is just an initial style so get it
set up we use
retransition the transform over a period
of time and we do the opacity as well
and then uh to get it out of view
initially we just
set its initial translate value to be
100 out of the viewport so it's sitting
up out of the window you can't see it
and then when it's checked uh what we
want to do to get that same effect of
the background fades in
and then then the thing slides down so
we just want to check we just adjust
the transition delay to not um
not do that transition for 400
milliseconds while the other thing is
fading in
so you can see on the on the modal close
input
we then transition the opacity and then
so when it's checked
the opacity is changed you could always
use rgba as well you don't have to use
opacity
and then we just make sure there's no
delay and when it's checked and i need
to make sure that it's not actually the
closed modal because then you will get
confusion where
when the close input is checked then
we'll get we'll try to target the
label below it and it'll get in a weird
state so we just use the not selector
to say well if if the input is not
closed modal that's
currently checked so we want to make
sure that when they launch the model we
don't get any weird behavior
then then target the motor closed label
and display it
there's a image carousel as well
this looks nice you may notice some
similarities
between this and the slide deck
so there's a lot going on this so
i got to be carried away with this talk
um i got caught in the meta process
of uh i did
as always i get caught up in the meta
process of creating slides and i ended
up creating a checkbox-powered slide
from my checkbox talk so and i and i
called it slicher bob
i was always like that man so the
carousel and slideshow bob have very
much
very similar in how they work
so we'll jump to the editor so i just
pushed this to github the slideshow bob
but basically it is
it is um just a bunch of classes here
and then i use sass because there's some
uh some crazy
um selectors going on there and a bit
like just not my brain trying to work
out all the math
because it needs to know how many slides
you have to calculate where it's
supposed to transform
the slide as you transition between each
slide so i've got this
mixing that loops over a variable so
i've got a variable slide count so in a
demo one there's 11 slides
it'll then loop over that and it'll work
out
all the calculation it needs to do so
there's lots of um working out well if
it's this slide number then you need to
divide it by 100 and work out the
percentage that needs to do based on the
slide count
and sas made that really easy and it's
got a nice build process so i just run
grunt and it'll generate based on the
slide count the css file
so the output here you can see
if i scroll down
so you can see it's putting out all
these crazy selectors to work out when
it needs to show the left and right
button when it needs to flip it based on
which count you're on
so like initially you've got the second
label that sits
on the right side and then when i go to
the second one then it suddenly needs to
position on the left side and you need a
third one there there's a lot going on
so sas
makes this a lot easier and i don't have
to worry about working out all the um
the calculations you can see like the
the four decimal places
percentage and it gets gets a little um
out of hand so sas makes it hugely
a much easier process
so quirks and bugs so it's not all uh
sun
sunshine and lollipops in um jetbox
world
so for a while there uh webkit couldn't
handle
uh checked and the general sibling
combinator
that's been fixed now and safari 5.1 and
chrome 13 were up to like chrome
900 now i think um
so yeah that's like a long gaunt thing
but if you have to support older
browsers especially safari which is only
up to six
uh it wouldn't actually activate the
styles so if you initially had
the checked attribute on an input it
would pick up these styles
but if you once you as a user you
checked another checkbox it wouldn't
actually pick it up
um so that was a that was a big issue so
it would work with a direct sibling
combinator but that
restricted you to the position of
a container that input should alter when
you check it
any of the kenai people there may have
noticed i had a lot of on-click empty
attributes
on the labels this would be because of
an issue in ios 5. um where
a label click clicking a label wouldn't
actually check the check box
and i figured out somehow that um
putting an empty on click on there
would actually give it a kick up the ass
and tell to check the checkbox um that
was a really nice bug but it was good to
find a solution to that um
but then you get the because of a click
event uh has a 300 millisecond delay you
get
uh that issue where it can be a bit slow
when it checks on is5 it's been fixed in
ios6 so
which is good uh downsides
it is a huge hack there's no
denying that there's
accessibility issues so i talked to a
good friend
jason kiss who's based in new zealand
he's a
very good accessibility expert no
just wanting to review and confirm my
beliefs that this is
horrible if you have screen ready users
and he confirmed that it was horrible
because the problem is that a label
can't have a role attribute to make it
appear as like a button
it's an invalid thing so a label cannot
ever be a button so like the
how i had the modal where the label
stalled like a button um a screen reader
would see a label and be like what the
hell is going on
you've got no way of switching um
switching uh so you've got the aria
attributes of like aria hidden
equals true and then when you switch to
display song you you can't
programmatically change attributes in
css that's where you need javascript
so three downfalls there
sometimes requires specific places of
markup and by sometimes i mean
all the time so you need you've got that
restriction of that it's only siblings
uh the sibling combinator so they need
to be on the same level so
like what i show with tabs you get that
sort of ugly placement of markup
and you get the crazy selectors too um
yeah so you get overly complex selectors
using the plus in tiller which can hurt
your head when you need to manually work
them out
so browser support
uh look at the browser ponies here
they're pretty cool uh
so basically basically means that they
support checked um
fancy is like when they support
transitions and all the other nice stuff
that um
makes it uh nicer to look at so
the other issue there ie9 didn't support
transitions it was the first one to
support
checked before that it didn't support it
ie10 introduced
the uh the transitions animations so you
can get the nice
effects going on here and otherwise it's
pretty safe to
to hack around with it
so the the future maybe um
so there is a spec writer who works with
google called tab atkins who on his
blog wrote a proposal on there
for being able to toggle any element so
introduce these properties there's four
of them i've got two here called
toggle star so toggle states toggle
share
so going back to that modal example
on that modal i can say well this
model's got two states it's
either hidden or displayed the idea is
this
is well you can have more than two
states so you can just keep cycling
through
and have you know as many states as you
need and then
and then i can use that checked pseudo
class
on any element so it doesn't have to be
an input and i can react to when when
the state changes
and then using the toggle share which is
which works the same way as a four
attribute on a label
so i can associate uh toggling of state
with another element i can just say well
on this model uh modal button
uh pass in a simple css selector
saying well you've got a you can alter
the toggle state of that element
and then you can avoid those crazy
selectors that you saw um
makes it much easier but at the moment
it's just a blog post on his personal
blog
um and who knows if you actually get
time to look at it and propose it and if
people accept it but i think that'd be
cool if you could have that
rather than using checkboxes and radios
to hack it
that's it slides
bootleg and slideshow bob are all up in
github you can check it out
thanks
you